الصوره كما تتابعونها الان من خلف مباشره
عبر هذا النقل المباشر لقناه العربيه من
داخل الميناء الاخضر بميناء بورسودان
تحديدا في الميناء الشمالي
292 من رعايه دوله الهند في السودان وصلوا
الى هذه المرحله بعد ان اكملوا كافه
الاجراءات المتعلقه باجلائهم من السودان
هنالك نحو 550 ايضا من افراد الجاليه
الهنديه او الرعايه الهنود في السودان
وصلوا امس وامس الاول الى مدينه بورسودان
شرق السودان
لاستكمال الاجراءات المتعلقه بترحيلهم
واجلائهم من شرق السودان الى ميناء جده
ومنها مباشره الى دوله الهند عبر الخطوط
الجويه
الهنديه هذه الاعداد المقدره من الهنود
تضاف اليها ايضا عدد من البعثات وعدد من
رعايا الدول الحديث هنا عن ما قامت به
المملكه العربيه السعوديه
امس وامس الاول
لعدد من الجاليات العربيه والاسيويه
والاوروبيه وصلوا الان الى المملكه
العربيه السعوديه بعد قليل ايضا ستصل قطعه
بحريه فرنسيه
من موظفي الامم المتحده في السودان
والبعثات الدبلوماسيه هنا هنا في بورسودان
حيث وصلت امس وامس الاول هنالك ايضا عدد
من رعايه اندونيسيا وعدد من الدول في
طريقهم من الخرطوم الى مدينه بورسودان
لاستكمال الاجراءات
الجلاء سواء كان عبر الميناء هنا في
بورسودان او عبر الجو ايضا في مدينه
بورسودان هذه القطعه البحريه الان
تحتاج الى ما يقارب الساعه
لاستكمال اجراءات اجراء كل من وصل الى هذه
المنطقه في الميناء الاخضر بعدها مباشره
ستحط في ذات المكان قاعده بحريه ايضا تتبع
لدوله الهند وعلى متنها ايضا القوات
البحريه الخاصه التي ايضا تعمل على تامين
وتعمل بتنسيق مع الجيش السوداني الذي يشرف
بصوره كامله على عمليات الاجلاء بتنسيق
ايضا مع الوحدات الاداريه في الشرطه ومع
البعثات ومع وزارات الخارجيه في عدد من
الدول
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات